durch meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge flecki bird
weil ich mir gedacht habe da heute ja
keine minecraft rüberkommen kann welcher
gestorben bin spiele ich doch mal ne
runde flap bird weil ich von den
spielern letzter zeit richtig angepisst
bilden und auch irgendwie aber auch
relativ süchtig geworden bin ich spritze
nahezu jedem schulfach mittlerweile
immer so ab und zu natürlich nicht in
der schule sondern nur in den pausen
aber ich spiele 24 runden alle die die
es nicht kennen bzw nicht wissen was ich
dir gerade überhaupt mache das ist ein
spiel fürs iphone deswegen ist die ganze
konstruktion auch anders die face cam
ist anders aufgebaut die tonqualität ist
bestimmt ein bisschen anders weiß micro
zehn meter von mir weg steht damit das
nicht in dieses bild da obendrein kommt
in die kamera was ihr hier gerade seht
harlow und zwar hab ich da meine kamera
aufgebaut das ganze sieht ein bisschen
oder 15 aus weil ich nicht wusste wie
ich das iphone sonst film soll weil man
dafür in die sonst an entwickler
passwort dingsbums braucht das habe ich
natürlich nicht aber sonst erkläre ich
euch erst mal ganz kurz das spiel ich
muss dafür immer so ein bisschen auf dem
bildschirm tippen und zwar ist es ein
spiel wo sein kleiner vogel durch tore
durch fliegen muss und wenn man sich das
ganze spiel erstmal so anguckt jetzt
hier als ganz normal orte normal
zuschauer und ihr denkt das ist ja
eigentlich relativ einfach also das ist
der erste eindruck es gibt mittlerweile
es gibt es gibt es mittlerweile für
android und für iphone also im app store
und in dem game store von android also
ladet euch einfach mal runter und postet
mir doch einfach mal euren highscore in
die google+ kommentaren besten mit ihnen
dem screenshot oder so wenn das geht es
gibt ja so seiten die push oder so wo
man screenshots hochladen kann dann
einfach die linke da rein und es wäre
echt krass weil ich kenne bisher keine
personen die über 107 gekommen ist es
ist ein kumpel von mir dass ich kein
bisher keine person die echt so hoch
gekommen ist und oder welche wird schon
wieder dunkel aber sonst würde ich sagen
meine high schools bisher 45 ich
versuche einfach mal darüber zu kommen
sonst spielt das spiel ist einfach ein
bisschen ich zeig euch mal wie das hier
geht man kann ich kann ja so darauf
tippen dann
dieser vogel halb hoch und runter so
jetzt komme ich durch erste türchen
zweite man kann das ganze eigentlich gar
nicht so du so gut kommentieren
durchdachten habe davon noch gar kein
richtiges let's play gesehen auf youtube
da dachte ich mir so ja kommen
das spiel ist eigentlich ganz
interessant also diese macher sind
natürlich schon längst millionäre weil
es spielt jeder mittlerweile alle videos
sind offen mein geld bei best vereins
bei facebook alle möglichen berichtigen
alle möglichen berichten die ich alle
bauern 19 alle möglichen leute berichten
wirklich über dieses spiel welt echt so
mega süchtig macht es so simpel es gibt
spiele die sind jahre in der entwicklung
die kommen nicht an die verkaufszahlen
dieses spiel am ersten tag hatte also
das ist echt mega krass ich versuche
jetzt einfach mal meinen high score
dieser aufnahme hier zu schaffen spiel
hat jetzt ein paarmal ist wahrscheinlich
sehr langweilig zum zuschauen
aber ihr könnt euch ja selbst auch man
selbst einfach mal runter laden die
märkte schon immer wenn ich sage immer
wenn ich fertig ist soll man es macht
halt echt
man denkt sich schon so fick dich so ein
bisschen die sounds sind auch sega also
die sounds möchte ich nicht an machen
wir diesen einfach
das ist ein bisschen komisch ich
versuche nur ein bisschen ich versuch
über 5 40 zu kommen das wird
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr machbar
sein dass er noch gar nicht so ein
langes video sein sollen doch was sein
damit ihr wenigstens überhaupt irgendwas
habt auch man bei ihr wisst ja wegen
schule abi dies das habe ich zurzeit
wenig zeit zur zeit wenig zeit komplett
abdeckt
nein das sind mal diese brenzlichen
situationen in dem man nie weiß ob ich
auf meinem bildschirm gerotzt wo man nie
weiß wie soll ich jetzt noch wagner
durch das nicht so eine situation ist
wenn ich weiß halt nie so bei manchen
situationen euch jetzt runter gehen oder
nicht
also ich runter gehen oder soll ich noch
mal drauf drückt wo das wachstum knopf
muss das ganze grab ein bisschen schräg
halten wegen der kamera
der vogel ist auch ein komischer vogel
der vogel besteht quasi was zwei
kartoffeln 2 möhren einem auge und einer
riesigen ananas ohne pflanzliches oben
dauern
also ich habe noch nie so einen vogel
gesehen wenn es irgendwann so ein vogel
gibt dann wäre es echt killer
also kommt alle leute die mich bisher
gefragt habe was das denn für ein spiel
die man dann als ich das vorgespielt
haben diese höhe das doch wohl einfach
spielens und schaffen alle nur 0 erst
mal am anfang die ersten fünf sechs
versuche weil es halt echt schwierig ist
man schätzt dass für ein wenn ich in den
torraum fliege muss sich ungefähr in der
mitte sein aber hier muss man einfach
weiter unten seine zehnte mann ich will
erfahren nur ein bisschen höher als im
moment lebt man mit laptop man meinen
bildschirm geht egal aus welchen ein
bisschen besser sein als 1000 ein
bisschen zweistellig ich möchte
vielleicht einfach nur dieses spiel
empfehlen wer falls die aggressionen
habt und die eventuelle handy kaputt
machen wollte dieses spiel ist die beste
entscheidung ist echt gut dafür
ich kann euch ja gleich mal den ton an
machen aber das ist doch komme ich mache
ich jetzt mal in die wohnung mit dem
gehört was ist hier für eine scheiße ist
die ich wie immer ach das ist ja total
spiegelverkehrt egal drehe ich dass
nachher so der ton meine damen und
herren
sehr einfallsreich dieser vogel tut mir
so leid ist bei mir schon so oft
abgestürzt richtiges kugel sondern
gerade
na ja komm ich mache jetzt mal eine oma
jetzt noch aber mit dem ton war bisher
ganz gut ich mache jetzt mal auf die
hälfte damit nicht ganz so berühmt ist
und ich eventuell noch ein bisschen
darüber kommentieren kann also mein
highscore ist 45 wenn ihr das passt auch
mal wenn er das pack seite echt in
meinen augen seid ihr dann gut in meinen
augen ist man schon gut wenn man
irgendwas zweistellige schafft in diesem
spiel weil die meisten ich bisher kerner
meister von 7 oder so aber dieses spiel
hier ist echt so krass heftig
dieser phase also der für vogel den den
mag ich echt irgendwie ich mache das
cover vom spiel aber als ich hab halt
wenn wir was soll ich hab das spiel
entdeckt als ich dass wir wirklich in
videos gesehen habe sind videos gesehen
dachte erst mal so nicht ist das leben
als retro game oder so keine ahnung
video verstehe ich jetzt nicht und dann
habe ich das wirklich im app store
gesehen und dachten wir suchen kannst du
dir mal richtig runter laden ist
ich weiß jetzt kostenlos ist ich glaube
es ist kostenlos über oder 79 cent
kostenlos oder 79 cent aber ich bin 90
cent
das ist ein fünftel vom döner dort kann
man ich habe eigentlich grant allein
ich rechne übrigens immer ein döner naja
freunde ich würde sagen das ist jetzt
erst mal von philipp über dieses spiel
bringt mich zum wahnsinn
also ladet solche einfach runter ich
finde es extrem geil
ja ihr könnt auch eine bewertung lassen
wenn ihr wollt aber naja egal ich würde
sagen ich hoffe euch das gefallen wenn
ihr noch mal irgendwie sowas sehen wollt
wenn ich ein spiel für iphone spieler
schreibst in die kommentare sonst
schaffe